DAYS.
THEY SEE ALL OF THESE
LEGISLATIVE SUCCESSES AS
HELPFUL.
>> JEREMY DIAMOND, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
>> TOP OFFICIALS OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION ARE NOT THE ONLY
ONES TOUTING THESE NEW PUBLIC
WORK PROJECTS MADE POSSIBLE BY
THE $1.2 TRILLION INFRASTRUCTURE
LAW PASSED LATE LAST YEAR.
IN FACT, LOTS OF REPUBLICAN
LAWMAKERS ARE TAKING CREDIT FOR
JUMP STARTING THESE PUBLIC WORK
PROJECTS IN THEIR DISTRICTS AND
STATES.
EVEN THOUGH MANY OF THEM VOTED
AGAINST THE INFRASTRUCTURE BILL
THAT IS PROVIDING THE VERY
FUNDING FOR THESE PROJECTS.
THIS PAST WEEKEND, IOWA DEMOCRAT
LIZ MATHIS CALLED HINSON OUT FOR
TRYING TO TAKE CREDIT FOR THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL EVEN THOUGH
SHE VOTED NO.
>> SHE VOTED NO.
NOW, REMEMBER THAT.
BUT ALSO, TOOK CREDIT ABOUT TWO
WEEKS LATER FOR A PROJECT THAT
WAS FUNDED BY INFRASTRUCTURE
MONEY.
THAT IS NOT THE IOWA WAY.
>> REPUBLICAN CONGRESSWOMAN
HINSON HAD POSTED THIS STATEMENT
WHERE SHE TOLD CONSTITUENTS THAT
SHE, QUOTE, HELPED LEAD A
BIPARTISAN GROUP TO, QUOTE,
PRIORITIZE THE FUNDING, ADDING,
QUOTE, I'LL ALSO FIGHT TO INSURE
IOWANS' TAXPAYER DOLLARS
REINVESTED AT HOME IN IOWA.
OF COURSE, EXCEPT WHEN SHE'S
VOTING AGAINST THOSE INVESTMENTS
BUT SHE'S HARDLY THE ONLY
REPUBLICAN TRYING TO CLAIM
SUCCESS FOR SOMETHING THEY VOTED
AGAINST.
AT LEAST 14 CONGRESSIONAL
REPUBLICANS TRIED TO HAVE THEIR
CAKE AND VOTE AGAINST IT TOO.
CONGRESSMAN TONY GONZALEZ FROM
TEXAS ON THE LIST AFTER VOTING
AGAINST THE INFRASTRUCTURE BILL
IN NOVEMBER, CALLING IT
SOMETHING THAT WILL ONLY MAKE
MATTERS WORSE AND HOLD OUR
COUNTRY BACK.
MONTHS LATER, HE POSTED A BIG
ANNOUNCEMENT ON HIS WEBSITE
TOUTING HE SECURED $75 MILLION
FOR A CREEK RESTORATION PROJECT
IN HIS CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT.
THAT MONEY, OF COURSE, CAME FROM
THE INFRASTRUCTURE BILL THAT HE
VOTED AGAINST.
FLORIDA SENATOR RICK SCOTT DID
THE SAME THING.
HE VOTED AGAINST THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL, THEN HE
WENT TO TOUR A NEW EMBANKMENT IN
THE EVERGLADES BRAGGING ABOUT
SECURING AN UNPRECEDENTED $1
BILLION FOR EVERGLADES
RESTORATION, THE LARGEST SINGLE
AMOUNT EVER ALLOCATED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, UNQUOTE.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT WAS
GIVEN THE MONEY FOR THE PROJECT
FROM THE INFRASTRUCTURE BILL
THAT SENATOR RICK SCOTT VOTED
AGAINST.
BUT IT'S NOT JUST
INFRASTRUCTURE.
WE ALSO SEE REPUBLICANS TRYING
TO CAPITALIZE ON IT'S ALSO THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN, YOU MIGHT
REMEMBER THAT, THE CORONAVIRUS
FUNDING PACKAGE PASSED BY
CONGRESS WHICH GAVE MONEY TO
SMALL BUSINESSES AND TO
RESTAURANTS.
WE FOUND AT LEAST 11 REPUBLICAN
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS WHO VOTED
AGAINST THE BILL AND TURNED
AROUND AND BRAGGED ABOUT
SECURING FUNDS THEY VOTED
AGAINST.
SOME OF THEIR TWEETS THAT MAKE
HAY DESPITE HAVING VOTED NAY.
GREG PENCE TELLING HIS DISTRICT,
HELP IS ON THE WAY.
TROY BALDERSON TELLING
CONSTITUENTS TO MARK THEIR
CALENDARS TO APPLY FOR THE
FUNDING HE VOTED AGAINST.
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS MORE
POLITELY THAN US ALSO NOTICED
THIS PHENOMENA.
>> EVEN MY REPUBLICAN FRIENDS IN
CONGRESS, NOT A SINGLE ONE OF
THEM VOTED FOR THE RESCUE PLAN.
I'M NOT GOING TO EMBARRASS ANY
ONE OF THEM, BUT I HAVE HERE A
LIST OF HOW BACK IN THEIR
DISTRICTS, THEY'RE BRAGGING
ABOUT THE RESCUE PLAN.
>> WE ALSO HAVE A LIST.
A FEW LISTS, ACTUALLY, BECAUSE
THERE WAS ALSO OF COURSE THE
MASSIVE OMNIBUS SPENDING BILL.
AT LEAST TEN REPUBLICANS WHO
VOTED NO AND TOOK CREDIT FOR
FUNDING.
ELISE STEFANIK FROM NEW YORK,
QUOTE, I HAVE WORKED TO SECURE
MANY CRITICAL WINS FOR UPSTATE
NEW YORK AND THE NORTH COUNTRY.
ALSO POSTING A LIT OF MORE THAN
TEN LOCAL PROJECTS THAT WOULD
NOW HAVE FUNDING BECAUSE OF THIS
SPENDING BILL THAT SHE VOTED
AGAINST.
SEVERAL OF THESE REPUBLICANS DID
NOT RESPOND TO OUR REQUEST FOR
COMMENT BUT THOSE WHO DID MADE
STATEMENTS ALONG THE LINES OF,
HEY, I SUPPORTED THE FUNDING FOR
THAT.
I JUST DIDN'T LIKE THE WHOLE
BILL, OR AS HINSON'S OFFICE
TSDZ, QUOTE, SINCE THE BILL WAS
SIGNED IT TO LAW, THIS MONEY WAS
GOING TO BE SPENT REGARDLESS.
IF THERE'S FEDERAL MONEY ON THE
TABLE, THE CONGRESSWOMAN IS
DOING TO DO EVERYTHING SHE CAN
TO MAKE SURE IT'S REINVESTED IN
IOWA, UNQUOTE.
THIS IS NOT ENTIRELY A NEW
PHENOMENON, AND THOUGH IN
GENERAL NOW IT'S REPUBLICANS
GUILTY HERE, PROGRESSIVE
DEMOCRAT AYANNA PRESSLEY OF
MASSACHUSETTS ALSO VOTED AGAINST
THE INFRASTRUCTURE BILL.
SHE DID IT AS A PROTEST BECAUSE
THE BUILD BACK BETTER ACT WAS
NOT ATTACHED TO INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND THE CONGRESSWOMAN LATER
TURNED AROUND AND TOOK CREDIT
FOR FUNDING PROVIDED FROM THE
BILL THAT SHE VOTED AGAINST.
THE LARGER POINT YOU CAN'T HAVE
IT BOTH WAYS.
FOR MANY IN CONGRESS, IT'S EASY
TO VOTE NOW ON CONTROVERSIAL
MASSIVE SPENDING PACKAGES AND
TURN AROUND AND HAMMER THOSE WHO
VOTED YES AS BIG SPENDERS AND
IRRESPONSIBLE WITH YOUR TAX
DOLLARS.
NO ONE LIKES EVERYTHING IN A BIG
PIECE OF LEGISLATION, BUT YOU
GOTTA VOTE AND THEN YOU HAVE TO
STAND BY YOUR VOTE IF YOU VOTE
NO, DON'T TAKE CREDIT FOR WHAT'S
IN THE BILL.
THAT'S JUS